Sure
you often give advice to young adults to
help them avoid some of the pitfalls of
life.
Any advice for those of us who are
40 plus who have already faltered?
Look first I'm,
this is Graham.
Everybody who 40 pluses
as already fault her,
but,
but I'm presuming that you mean faltered
in a manner that it appears to you to
be above out above the average.
Right.
Well,
okay.
What I would really recommend
is I think that you should,
if you haven't already,
you should go do the future authoring
program and maybe the past authoring
program too,
because you should figure
out exactly how you faltered.
Like what exactly did you do wrong
by your own buy your own analysis,
right?
I'm not saying,
well what social rules did you break?
Although that's not a
bad initial guideline.
It's like,
so in the self authoring suite,
there's a past authoring module and it
asks you to break your life I to 70 parks
and then to consider the emotionally
significant or practically significant
events within each epoch
in the detail out there,
emotional nature and their
consequences and so on.
And one of the things you
might want to figure out is,
well,
when you say that you faltered,
like what do you mean exactly?
And I mean exactly go over your
life with a fine tooth comb.
This is what Aleksandr
Solzhenitsyn did by the way,
in the Gulag before he
wrote the Gulag archipelago,
he went over his life and said,
okay,
well like where did I go wrong?
What did I squander?
What mistakes did I make and what did I
do right so that you can orient yourself
now and then you want to think,
and this is why we built the
future authoring program.
Well look,
you got 40 years left man.
So what do you want them to be like?
So what do you want to aim at?
You know at least how are you
going to minimize the misery if,
if,
if nothing else.
And so you need a plan and then what you
need to do is to figure out how to work
day to day so that you
incrementally approach that plan.
So I have another chapter in this new
book called compare yourself to who you
were yesterday.
Rather than to who someone else's today.
That's really a useful psychological
stance for someone who's 30 and over in
particular to a 20 year olds can still
kind of compare themselves to other 20
year olds because all 20 year
olds in some way are the same,
but 40 year olds are really
different from each other and so,
or 30 year olds for that matter.
So you might think,
okay,
well
ear,
here's a,
here's a meditative strategy
for for ceasing to falter.
You could wake up in the morning or you
could do this at night before you go to
bed and you could think,
okay,
look,
I want to structure my day
tomorrow so that when I,
when I'm done with the day,
my life is in slightly better order
than it was when I woke up this morning.
Just slightly better because
incremental progress is massively,
massively effective because
it bears a exponential fruit.
I just like a bank account,
um,
compounds,
incremental progress compounds with time.
So you can get up in the
morning and you could think,
okay,
there's some things in my life
that I could put in order today.
They're usually things
you don't want to do.
As I mentioned earlier,
what could I do today that would help
put my life in order that I wouldn't do?
And you have to ask yourself.
You can't tell yourself.
You have to ask yourself
what would you do?
And then maybe you have to say,
well,
or maybe you have to say under what
conditions would I be willing to do
something to put my life
in further ordered today?
What little reward would
I need to give myself?
And these have to be questions you
can't like take out the whip and boss
yourself wrong because you'll find that
you're a terrible master and a worst
slave.
And so you can get a long
ways if you look low enough.
One of the things Carl Jung said,
which I really liked was that modern
people don't see God because they don't
look low enough.
They don't have the humility.
Now you said that you
have already faulted.
So it sounds like you've got
to humility already intact.
So I would say think about what you want.
Think about what you know
around you isn't set right.
Cause you'll know it.
Make a list of things that are
around you that aren't right.
And then start thinking about
small things you can do,
like trivial things that even a fool
like yourself could manage that would
orient you in the right direction and
help straighten out your life and try that
for a year before you decide
that you're a failure.
You know?
Because you'll find that if you
put that into practice for a year,
that things will be a lot better.
And like I said,
you got 40 years left,
so you're not,
you're not done yet.
And so
the other thing I would say too is
it isn't exactly that.
I would say forgive
yourself because you know,
that's just a cliche.
But I would say that once you've decided,
once you,
what you've done wrong and
you've put into practice some,
some strategies to rectify that,
that don't,
you don't have to beat yourself any
more than is necessary for you to learn,
which is a good rule of thumb with
regards to treating yourself and also to
treating other people.
So
yeah.